good morning John today's vlog where
this is gonna be a little bit weird I'm
right now in an antique mall I found a
thing
that I'm so amazed by that I just can't
help but take it apart and if now in my
home this thing is at least 25 pounds
it's made entirely of metal and it can
do addition and subtraction and kind of
multiplication not real obviously a
calculator that can do addition and
subtraction these days not impressive
when it was purchased it probably cost
around as much as a really nice laptop
today I don't know how this works but
that's what I'm gonna try to figure out
today there are a number of amazing
things going on all at once inside of
this machine first most simply let's
just put in the number 99 that's $0.99
both of the dials will count up to nine
if we add one to the 99 there we had one
cent we're gonna get a buck right now I
know how the first column happened
there's a pin that tells in the Machine
that to roll this dial the first column
dialed one digit now that makes sense
but then it gets carried forward and
that is amazing to me what how did this
machine that is just a machine figure
that out that's what we want to know and
as far as I'm concerned there's only one
way to find out so let's take it apart
Oh what is this the dead animal
something crawled in there and died like
a thousand years ago I have no idea but
I touched it this thing comes off and
I've got one of these I should now be
able to lift this off oh I'm sure I can
fuzzy on the inside oh man now this just
got way cooler there's been something
rolling around in here I could hear it
it's a dime 1980 so it's not that old
how does it stop at the right place how
does it carry the number how does the
subtract function or nerdy yes yes it's
nerdy it's very nerdy each one of these
parts have to be
Bijlee stamps how do do come on I hate
flathead screws so much right now a lot
of these screws are really stuck which
is not all that surprising we actually
have to be depressing a button in order
to access this screw so that somewhere
those the only four screws yes well
something's happened oh okay
this is the back of the number plate
when you push each of the numbers it
pops down into one of those nine slots
there I got it I figured it out when you
push down a number two things happen one
that depression will push down this
lever a little bit and that actually
allows for this thing up here the gear
that actually turns the number wheel to
actually start moving how much it moves
is a question of which key got pushed
down whichever button is pushed will
actually block that at a certain point
if nothing stops it go all nine you get
nine if it stops like halfway in the
middle and then it stops five in an only
count five so this oil at how my fingers
right now was put on here by someone in
a factory in the 1930s the numbers are
somehow responsible for the digit
carrying boy am I glad I didn't have to
manufacture these things for a living I
would have not been good at it so at
zero this notch holds this pin and this
pin when you move it out of the way it
just automatically advances that pin is
the secret so it's the kind of thing
that we would never make today but it
has in its functionality a beauty that I
am a big fan does so many things all at
once in it it's powered entirely by the
crank of the hand thanks to all the
people who you know we won't remember
the names of put all their time and
energy into the creation of these
devices so very neat so very very neat
John I'll see you on Tuesday
you